do you think in places of political
liability ahead of the midterms
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound
naughty language president biden lashing
out at fox news white house
correspondent peter ducey for asking a
question about inflation
i love the way schinkiss describes that
joe concha here now joe isn't it so
great to see this civility that joe
biden
promised
yeah pyro joe biden is not the
commander-in-chief it appears that he's
the curmudgeon in chief and and he's
increasingly angry with the press i mean
this is just the last week alone what a
stupid son of a [ __ ] he said that
yesterday he just played it what a
stupid question that's what he said
about jackie heinrich a white house
correspondent also for fox and he said
to phil wegman of real clear politics if
you don't understand that you're in the
wrong business so look the 46th
president is understandably upset right
uh he is build back better bill
trillions of social spending uh that's
dead in its current form his party's
attempt to overhaul election law via
federal takeover was also thwarted uh in
both cases by members of his own party
right inflation's at a 40-year high
crime is spiraling out of control
russia's thumbing its nose at us while
preparing to invade ukraine without any
fear of reprisal so look this is from an
nbc news poll it's very important just
five percent of adults say mr biden has
performed better than expected as
president and that's one of the many
first that's one of the lowest we've
seen he's also not seen as likable
anymore was he was at 53 when he came
into office as far as likability he's
now at 38 but kudos to peter goosey for
laughing it off he told sean hannity
last night there are much bigger things
to focus on he didn't make himself the
story obviously the russian invasion of
ukraine should be top of mind or
inflation so peter ducey handled that
perfectly
i think i saw stephen miller on twitter
put it best he said jim acosta would
need a neck brace if he actually was
addressed to in that way
himself the victim and the story so that
was just perfect
i mean when
the president first entered office all
the questions were about his favorite
ice cream flavor or what he would do
better than former president trump the
media has turned on him in recent weeks
take a listen to this
okay
who feels like we are in a better place
now than we were a year ago show of
hands
[Music]
no one believes we're in a better spot
now mr biden does need a reset because
he's lost his identity a bit he's no
longer seen as competent and effective
yeah and also chuck todd pointed out
that of all the areas public perception
has changed regarding president biden
the fact that people don't see him as
easy going and likable is the most
damaging which sort of brings us back to
the sob comment that he made to peter
ducey as well
precisely and i'm not so sure it's media
turning on him but they're simply
reporting what people are telling them
so when margaret brennan does that focus
group you saw on cbs or chuck todd is
simply reporting uh
poll results from an nbc news poll and
that's just like giving scores to the
football games right and right now joe
biden is down many many touchdowns and
all those important issues that we
talked about but from a personality
standpoint that was always kind of
biden's backstop right that well you
know the guy's the he's the guy from
scranton he's folksy and and he makes
gaffes but you know that's joe biden
just being human but now he just comes
across as and i hate to use this analogy
but it's the only thing that comes to
mind an angry old man who simply cannot
take a fair question without lashing out
and for people to say well it's
different with biden
when trump did the same exact thing
that is the biggest punchline probably
in social media right now right yeah
it was quite the moment on tv yesterday
joe thank you for sharing your
perspective on it this morning we
appreciate it of course great to see you
guys see you tomorrow bye okay hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now